invite à découvrir un des plus beaux
villages des bords de loire le village
de brémont la commune étaient installés
au départ sur une île une île où il y
avait derrière à la fois le cher et
l'indre des terres alluviales qui était
donc très riche où on cultivait le
chanvre le chambres utilisées pour les
cordages et les voiles de la batellerie
ce fut donc un commerce qui passait par
le port de brémont et l'hiver les
habitants de la commune
ce livre est aussi à l'activité de pêche
une pêche aux engins que je vous invite
à découvrir maintenant cette nuit et ben
il est rentré ce poisson là voilà que
l'on appelle un barbillons sa fourche et
pour pouvoir le mettre dans le fond
c'est par passion que dominique chevreau
s'attache à maintenir la tradition de la
pêche aux engins en loire
c'est pour partager ce patrimoine de la
vie des hommes et du fleuve qu'il
conserve précieusement le matériel
utilisé jadis par les pêcheurs devrais
m'en lasse comment on va aller voir
c'est un des derniers bateaux qui a fait
la pêche du saumon en hiver et de
l'alose au printemps c'est à dire que
c'est un bateau qui servait est ce qu'on
appelait à la pêche aux filets barrage
de 3-2 3 aller 1 2 3 de son enfance à
brême ont dominé chevreau se rappelle
avec émotion
l'épopée d'une pêche en loire
aujourd'hui disparu onze bateaux dans
cette cabane un cheveu arrivée et
l'influencé dans l'ambiance était
joyeuse
j'ai été voir dans le bateau dans le
vivier qu'on appelle un sens tino en
effet c'est le plus beau poisson que je
ne reverrai certainement plus c'était un
saumon qui faisait presque un mètre
trente donc cédé s'ouvrir qui sont
gravés à jamais même si maintenant j'ai
quelques photos et que les gens que
j'emmène avec moi vois des photos et
voient ce que ce que ce sont les saumons
mais en effet ce saumon je ne
l'oublierai pas quoi tu vas tenir la
corde et imagine que ma main ça soit la
queue de poisson
travers un après midi sur l'eau à
travers la découverte des techniques de
la pêche de nos ancêtres
la jeune génération s'approprie une
loire nourricière oublier des cartes
postales
voilà et s'arme sa remontée comme ça
qu'on appelle poisson le poisson et on a
pu le récupérer parce que du coup on a
beau avoir tout connu mettre le doigt
dans la bouche sans risque rien ça
apprend des choses sur la loire alors
qu'on habite juste à côté
non j'aime bien et c'est facile regarde
les gondoles à venise
j'ai avec le bâton la scène cliquant
s'appelle où j'ai bougé le bateau là et
que j'étais trop derrière la halle et
j'ai été vraiment touchée de voir là
cette fraîcheur des ventes cette
expérience qui est d'ailleurs unique et
qu'on a la chance de pouvoir profiter
dans un cadre similaire des matériels
anciens avec savoir faire et avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'amour de la part
dominique vraiment est porteur d
d'un patrimoine est d'une richesse
extraordinaire pour bien connaître
brémond village de loire je vous propose
une rencontre avec michel verdier
bonjour je vous êtes un passionné de la
loire et de ses bords de loire vous
connaissez bien brémond qu'est ce qui a
fait qu'à une époque
bremont et a été si riche et si
prestigieux je crois que brémond en fait
tire justement sa richesse de son sol
son sol qui était dans une ville qui a
favorisé les cultures assez enfin une
culture cas c'est assez développée au
19e siècle et au début du xxème qui est
la culture du chanvre le champ qui était
utilisé essentiellement pour fabriquer
des cordes dévoile des du matériel en
fait pour la batellerie
c'est ça qui a développé le port et le
port en fait c'est un port ou faisait du
commerce ont commercé évidemment par app
world et ce commerce a généré derrière
ça des gens qui ont eu la capacité
effectivement de se construire de belles
maisons telles qu'elles sont là sur le
port des maisons du 19e souvent et qui
ont permis effectivement le
développement de brémont puisqu'en fait
on a compté plus de 1700 habitants ici
ce qui est quand même une commune
importante pour le département du rhône
alors aujourd'hui la moitié des
habitants mais vraiment est toujours
très fréquenté et plus par les
promeneurs les touristes les cyclistes
qu'est ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
brémond et attractif
quand je crois vraiment et attractif
parce que j'abhorre c'est sur le
parcours de la loire à vélo qui espère
un parcours qui maintenant plus de vingt
ans puisque est presque trente ans
d'existence en fait
et puis le fait qu'il y ait pas de
constructions sauvages en quelque sorte
puisque comme c'est complètement
inondable donc non constructible
on ne peut qu améliorer l'existant
maintenant les anciens quand tu sois qui
peuvent vraiment 10 brémond les
pissotières tout ça vient vraiment les
pissotières c'est tout simplement parce
que sur le port il y avait six
pissotière qui était construite qui sont
encore pour deux qui sont existantes
partiellement certainement que brémond
était un port
et on sait bien que dans l'epr il n'y a
pas que l'eau qui coule voilà je vous
invite à venir vous même découvrir cette
magnifique commune de brémont